when you look at what he said online
again the you can give the example of
bottom Mission so and so forth that's
how that that's basically slang that's
how people talk and that's what you're
not understanding in terms of let's look
at your example which is completely
ridiculous because what you're saying is
guess what he said this online therefore
he should be convicted based on it
online well that's the influence you're
making basically online you get this
example you said he's trying to defraud
them because online what he actually
said was this in that video because I
know the video you're referring to he
says in the same video he says oh I'm
gonna take all the money in the same
video he says I'm gonna get 50 50. in
the same video he says I'm gonna give 50
30 70 30 because you know 20 you know
I'm gonna tell us for um tax purposes
but then I ain't gonna pay the taxes and
hence why you're making the claim for
fraud